all right hello everyone good morning
thank you for joining me on the second
day of Copenhagen developers Festival
I'm Adrienne banza Teka and today I'd
like to talk to you about variables of
the voracious variety now I really like
to use the website thesaurus.com so
you'll see that there will be lots of
other words in here that might mean some
other things because we want to be
succinct and so let's get started great
clicker is working so who here has heard
this quote it has been seen time and
time again there are only two really
difficult things or hard things in
computer science that is Cash inv
validation and naming things who has
heard this quote before from Phil
Carlton and who tends to agree that
naming things if the clicker works is
really really difficult
that's why you're here right yes so this
is exactly what this talk is about so if
this was not what you were intending I
will not be hurt go ahead and go to
another talk but this is what we will
focus on today naming things
specifically we're going to talk about
why is naming so important we have a gut
feeling why this is important and what
we do about it but sometimes we can't
really articulate what that actually
means why it is important then we'll
also talk about why it's difficult and
what really makes it so hard for us to
choose the best names after that we'll
go into the three C's of what I consider
great variables and those are tips and
guidelines that we can finally set for
ourselves to help us create better
variable names and lastly we'll go
through some variable variables to see
how we can put this into
practice so the first thing why is
naming
important
well naming is a way of placing order in
our world it's a way to help us
differentiate things it's a way for us
to see our world and make sure that we
know what we're talking about there's so
many different things in the world and
we want to know what we're talking about
when we talk to you when we talk to our
family when we discuss things when I
teach you something we want to know what
it is that we're talking about and so
when we are naming things take for
example this cat that was very soon
adopted by me we place names on
important things right or inanimate
objects Cars toys I don't know but
sometimes we also choose names for
animals and so when you first receive
this picture or when you're thinking
about adopting an animal like I did I
saw this photo and then I said okay what
am I going to name this thing because
this is going to soon be my pet and when
you start thinking about the different
names you go okay maybe I think Oreo
because this is a tuxedo cat it's black
and white it's something cute and when I
think of an Oreo those attributes remind
me of something happy like an Oreo so
maybe I choose this name because this is
the meaning I place behind that name or
maybe I choose the name Domino because
this is apparently a very pop popular
name for tuxedo cats there's black and
white maybe you go and be very direct
and say tux it's a very clear name
because that is the breed of the cat but
in the end I ended up going with Onyx
because it was a little bit more unique
I would know that is specifically my cat
and this was the name that the Foster
gave her and she ended up recognizing
and so I chose
Onyx and if you'll believe it or not
when we choose names we also do the same
kind of method of thinking ideally when
it comes to our kids so take for example
my own
name who here has asked their parents
where they got the name you know how did
they choose their name how did they end
up giving their name you probably have
some like really interesting story
there's like a warrior meaning behind it
or there's like a really special person
in your family that you've been named
after I asked my mom the same question
I'm like why how did you choose Adrian I
mean in the beginning I didn't like it
but I ended up growing to really like
the name and no joke you you've heard it
here first at Copenhagen developers
Festival the reason I got my name Adrien
spelled this way is quote my mom was
walking through the de department store
and she saw a particular designer tag of
Adrien
vadini and so that is how I got my name
so I'm like thankfully you didn't choose
anything else else that was a little bit
weirder a little bit so there you go
that's how we got my
name now when we talk about
scientifically naming things we have to
be a little bit more straightforward we
need to have a process behind it we need
to have some rules in place because we
can't just willy-nilly choose a name
based on what we like although in
science in scientific nomenclature if
you are the first one to discover an
organism you do have some say in what
that name is going going to be but in
science we specifically choose a very
specific process for how we name things
this is extremely important because we
want to prevent confusion being very
specific allows any scientist in the
world to know exactly what organism you
are talking about could you imagine
talking to any developer and saying this
is what I mean on that particular
variable no matter where you are in the
world you could have a conference like
this and you'd all immediately
understand that's what's so cool about
being very very specific and so we
should take a not a note from the
scientists our fellow scientists because
in theory we are computer scientists by
occupation so being very very
specific this is important
why who here in this in this room is
also called Adrien just by
chance are you are you kidding me that
is awesome I don't even have to go to my
second and third example thank you
Adrian so there's another Adrian in the
room and if I were to yell out Adrien or
somebody yells out Adrian in the room
both of us are probably going to look at
that person because it's not specific
enough we need a more specific
identifier we need something maybe like
a last name do you mind sharing your
last name CL so unless someone says Aden
glow or Adrien banaka then we don't know
who we are referring to we don't know
who we're talking about and so this is
again coming back to the point of being
very specific allows us to know exactly
what we are trying to
convey this was not the case in the
1700s best or before the 1700s we would
have some organisms or things that were
floating around and people would use
different names for them so for example
this picture here maybe there are some
biologists here maybe they know what
this is but in the past you would have
people saying oh this was a white oak in
their observations in daily life they
might have described or taken notes or
talked about this particular tree and
called it a white oak on the other hand
somebody else somewhere else may have
said oh this is a rounded Oak maybe
their particular tree was a a little bit
rounder or for whatever reason decided
to use that
identifier and then yet another person
might say a rough Oak these are all
three variations of what this particular
tree has been called uh in the past and
has been
misidentified so this is actually
quarkus Alba which is the White Oak but
to take make matters worse so knowing
all of these different identifiers that
are now floating around to potentially
describe this particular tree
you now also have different trees being
named White Oak so maybe somebody else
goes oh this is a strange White Oak that
I am seeing not knowing that that is not
a white oak and yet using the same name
to identify that particular tree even
though it's
wrong so laying out this Foundation we
see that all of this
misidentification and misnaming things
leads to a lot of confusion and that's
not far off from what we can experience
as developers in
programming we do have uh your neighbor
to the Northeast you think
carlas he is a Swedish naturalist who
has been uh credited with giving us the
unique uh naming structure that we have
for every organism today so you may have
heard of binomial naming clicker is not
working with me today and so every
organism in the world you can think him
Carl
for having a binomial name thank you
Carl so having a binomial name gets us
to that specificity having that binomial
name allows any scientist in the world
to know exactly what they are talking
about so when you take a look at this
let's see let me go back here because I
can't
see so in a binomial name you have two
parts by meaning two we have the genus
and we have the species modifier the
genus is kind of like the the top level
family of organized characteristics that
one might group a certain set of things
into and then you have a species
modifier which is like an adjective so
if we were to relate this to the Rel uh
to the example earlier Adrien would be
the family or the genus name and then
the species modifier would be glow or
banza taka to further identify and be
specific about what we're talking
about and so for us homo sapiens this is
our human name this is our binomial name
and this is why it is incredibly cool
incredibly important to be super super
specific this is why it is so
important so okay we know that it is
important Adrien why is it difficult so
again we may have this gut feeling in
our uh stomach but sometimes we may not
be able to articulate it but I will go
through some reasons why this may be
difficult first guidance on naming is
mostly syntactical when you look through
all of the different materials on the
internet in papers in books there are a
lot of things telling us how our
variable names should look so when we
get these kinds of rules for ourselves
we have things around casing right so
they tell us what casee do you use when
do you use it when do you not use it and
they tell us how our variable looks or
we get a lot of rules around length so
make sure it is not over or under a
specific character count or word count
make sure you're not abbreviating this
is something I do agree with and make
sure you're not using really really
short identifier names or even the the
letter I when we iterate through Loops
which stands for
iterator that is something that is still
very debated because as programmers we
see it all the time and so that might be
one thing where we You could argue and
say it is so well known in the industry
that you could get away with it especi
especially if you were using it within
the context of a loop but I would still
argue just make it more descriptive use
something that actually describes what
you're iterating
through so with these kinds of
syntactical pieces of guidance we get
rules like this avoid Kebab case since
it clashes with these subtraction synext
in some particular languages or use
camel case specifically for variable
names and I want to take note here make
note that of course there are coding
conventions and language conventions and
framework conventions and we should all
definitely stick to that but even
looking through those we get a lot of
rules that are like this that says use
this particular case or use this this
particular
convention same thing with length use
short identifier names for short Scopes
so again going back to that iterator
variable if you're only going to use it
when you iterate through something in a
very short scope it's okay for the name
to be short which I don't agree with and
keep name length to a 25 character
maximum so there are papers that talk
about all different kinds of studies
what is the proper uh amount of words
that you should use in a variable in one
paper that's been cited it said anything
that's longer than seven letters is
considered
long think about all the concepts we
have to convey I think we're always
going to have really really long uh
variable names with that particular
metric so having only syntactical
guidance having only rules that say this
is how our variable names should look
the meaning behind the names the words
that we choose to actually call our
variables the semantics of how we choose
variable names are less found on the
internet and less found unless you have
a really good Mentor or you yourself are
making sure to um teach that down to
your team there is not a lot to be found
on what to choose and how to choose the
names for your variables it is very very
much
lacking and within this realm of
semantics we get the rules like this use
meaningful descriptive names try making
identifiers self-documenting names
should be nonambiguous
okay we know what these are but even
these particular words when we add them
to our rules we don't know what those
are tell me what those look like what is
Meaningful what is descriptive what is
non-ambiguous to me might not be non
ambiguous to you what is descriptive to
some might be not descriptive to others
so these kinds of rules that are not as
explicit as the syntactical rules that
we have are not as helpful when we are
trying to decide what to name our
variables and not only that to make
matters even more difficult even if we
do decide toine identifiers that have
these characteristics names that are
meaningful descriptive self-documenting
non-ambiguous that's not enough because
variable names can be all of those
things but they also have to be
correct who here has seen a variable
that was very very explicit yet returned
not what it
said who here has seen a variable that
said I'm going to give you this in a
particular type implementation but it
actually didn't give it to you in that
type so even though we may have the most
clear name possible in terms of what it
is trying to to be it still needs to be
correct and even that is highly debated
so what is correct this is kind of a hot
take here but correct you would assume
there is only one way to say correct is
correct but not invariable naming and
here's why so there's this notion of
homonyms same words different
meaning and if we're going to be
specific because we are computer
scientists and we want to be specific in
the things that we are talking talking
about there are further branches that we
can be more granular with when we're
talking about homonyms specifically
homographs which literally translates to
same
writing and this just means that they
have the same spelling of a word but
they have a different meaning and we
have homophones which are literally same
sound and so these homophones are same
pronunciation but a different meaning so
when we look at at these homonyms that
exist in let's say the English language
you can kind of tell that it's going to
get a little bit trippy here so in
English we have the word
duck like I took my pet duck to the
Gucci
store duck the animal the noun the thing
the living thing or duck duck your head
before going down the stairs or while
going down the stairs you're physically
moving down moving your head down so
that you don't hit this
duck or take the word Rock there was a
great rock band last night it's
describing what type of band the genre
of music or almost four tons of solid
rock had to be removed to build this
tunnel or to build this skyscraper Rock
the actual material that had to be
removed having homographs in place
presents a lot of different issues and
we'll talk about those in a moment
homophones on the other their hand are
the ones where they have same
pronunciation but different meanings so
again in English we have write and WR as
in turn write at the next intersection
or like what I'm doing right now they
said write a book write a book they said
write to write
something and finally last example here
for homophones you there is hour and
hour there's you are with me for the
hour whether you like it or not and what
do you mean hour cake this is what I
tell myus husband every time I order
cake and he says this is our cake I said
what do you mean our
cake so
homophones homographs same writing same
spelling different meaning homophones
same pronunciation different meaning
same sound literally translated from the
Latin so
homonyms it's not just in English
there's also in Danish so when I Googled
uh what homonyms were in Danish I chose
a few and I tried for the life of me to
see what the different pronunciations
are but maybe this is one of the
homophones because cheers and bow sound
the same is that true skull and school
school school or school school school
okay so there or H is it is the j a y
sound or a g sound is it h
U and Christmas is also Yu so how do you
determine what you're talking about
context just like German German's
difficult too Danish is difficult too so
H H and H again do not know what you're
talking about unless you have some
context unless you have some
specificity and even in Tagalog which is
one of my native languages you have t
and to so to when you pronounce it that
way toot means to stand or t means us
and the other word there are many of
these but basa and basa if something is
wet you say it's and if you want to read
something you might
say very American accent marog is gonna
if marog is in the crowd she's going to
be like oh my gosh you have a very
American accent I try so homonyms not
limited to the English language and
maybe not as much of a problem in
programming because a lot of programming
is written in English nonetheless your
fellow developers who are writing might
have multiple languages in their head so
even if you are writing in English you
may have some words like this that take
up some of that cognitive load in their
head that make it a little bit harder
for them to distinguish what they're
talking about or maybe you are writing
in this particular language and so now
you have to take that into account when
you are identifying comp comprehending
and choosing
names so now we get to synonyms we have
homonyms now we have synonyms which are
the worst of the two so synonyms are
different words same
meaning and if we go
here let's see if I can increase here no
it's just going to do the main screen so
again thesaurus.com I am in love with
this tool it helps me choose different
words helps me be more precise but this
is also an issue because let's say we
take the name count which is something
very common that we probably have to do
in a function or have to name something
count to me when I think of the word
count I think of a very specific notion
of telling or counting and enumerating
through numbers but if I ask somebody
else count they might pick any one of
these other uh Concepts that may be
related to it so maybe counting is
specifically adding in their heads or
even counting is something to consider
does this count or does it not count or
having importance that counts so they're
all of these different concepts tied to
this particular word and that is the
problem with identifying and choosing
names is because of all of these
Concepts bless
you so we have names
count the words that we end up choosing
as our eye identifiers these are the
variable names that we end up putting
into code and if we took that example
count You' say some of the two concepts
there out of the many summation which is
a concept that is associated to the word
count or a perception or a Nuance or a
connotation there's all these different
things that may be tied to particular
word we call that a
concept count is also a numeration of
numbers it has this concept along with
many others I'm just simplifying this
example for the moment now let's say we
chose one of those synonyms and we
decided to use tally Tally has its own
set of Concepts it has keep count right
or it has to mark because when you tally
something you know you tally and you
make a mark every time you are keeping
count or uh keeping count or marking
something up you tally something where
it gets really really frustrating is
tally also has the notion of summation
so again depending on who is using the
word depending on what concepts are in
that developer's head you may be
considering one set of Concepts and you
may be considering another set of
Concepts and that is exactly what this
particular paper concise and consistent
naming by flan and marus it was publish
in 2006 they actually published another
paper called concise and consistent
naming 10 years later later and the
funny thing is they found that even with
all of the findings which some of them I
am showing you today they are they have
not changed in
application we are still having trouble
identifying variables we are still
having trouble comprehending them we're
still having trouble getting to the
ideal state of having every single name
that we talk about be very explicit
about what we're trying to
convey and I'm going to show you a
couple um figures that they have shown
when it comes to the problems of
synonyms and
homonyms so this first one a homonyms
pose an obstacle for program
comprehension because we have to take
all of those elements into account so
when we take the homonyms whether they
are different uh whether they are
homophones or homographs we increase the
size of the concepts that we must hold
in our head when we are either uh
reading the code or writing the code we
say this could mean this or this could
mean this and if we are not specific
enough they for the next developer who
does decide to read that name will have
the same problem comprehension becomes
way more difficult because of all of the
different concepts they have to take
into
account in their figure B in their paper
synonyms unnecessarily increase the
domain of N and the relation R raising
the learning effort of the language you
used so again similar to the last
example when you add homonyms and
synonyms together synonyms together I
want to say Sy synonyms together again
you are just continuing to expand the
domain with which you keep in your head
all of the different concepts all of the
different connotations all of the
different meanings those all go into
your head whether you think about it or
not so when you are reading a a variable
name that is ambiguous or is not very
very explicit or clear when you have
this domain space of all the different
concepts that it might be related to
that goes into your comprehension you
are reading it and you are thinking oh
maybe summation oh maybe enumeration oh
maybe to keep count when if you had just
chosen a more specific name or a more
clear name you can remove some of those
Concepts you can be way more explicit
and you can and make that cognitive load
a little bit less because you know
exactly what you're talking talking
about the third figure here is when
encountering name N1 so like count or
tally all the n's here um The Words the
names the reader must take concept C1 C2
into account so this is exactly what we
just talked about and their ideal state
is that we get to this that for every
name that we choose we explicitly convey
one and only one
concept this is a very very wild dream
this is why 10 years later they say this
is still not really happening because
it's somewhat very difficult to find
that first even if you chose all of look
through all the dictionary words that we
have we tend to use a lot of compound
names so we choose two or more words to
convey the concept that we're trying toh
talk about in programming and sometimes
with the problems of synonyms homonyms
and not being accurate with what we are
choosing that just again increases the
confusion on why we can't name our
variable names
correctly and just to put the cherry on
top for why everything is uh why naming
is difficult in a different paper called
how developers choose names I believe uh
felan who's here also spoke about this
when 334 developers were asked to choose
47 variable names the median probability
that two would choose the same was just
6.9% other than being a really nice
percentage it is incredibly telling that
with all of these issues today when
choosing words that we are not getting
to the right
words so now understanding why it is
difficult and why it is important how do
we actually choose better V better
variable names then how do we get to
these one name one concept type of
ideas this is where I come to the three
C's of great naming and this was heavily
inspired Again by the concise and
consistent naming paper so I don't
promise to take credit for all of it but
I do take credit for how I'm going to
explain it to
you consistent concise
correct there's variations of this
guidance that is shared everywhere but
in order for us to get to this
understanding consistent to me means the
identify needs to be unique enough to
convey the concept so whenever you
needed to do let's say a variable rename
or you needed to find a particular name
throughout all of the methods or all of
the classes in your program you are able
to distinctly find that particular name
and be sure that that is the the very
explicit concept that you're either
trying to rename to change to refactor
this is the thing that you are talking
about so a good example of this is when
you say account
number somewhere it's number somewhere
it's account num somewhere it's account
number somewhere it's act n
m it's these types of things where when
I say consistent it has to be the same
identifier enough to uniquely convey the
concept
concise the identifier needs to
accurately convey the concept and
minimize the related concept space as
much as possible so while there is a way
to choose a name there is a way to be
too generic about it for example the one
they give in the paper is a function
that would uh transform they called the
initial variable name
transformation and while that is
actually concise it wasn't concise
enough because what is actually
happening in the function was
permutation permutation is a more
concise version of a transformation so
generally speaking transformation can
mean many different things permutation
specifically means this particular way
to calculate so by choosing a more
concise Name by using thesaurus.com and
getting to the essence of what it is
that you're trying to convey you can
help your fellow developers limit that
concept space that is being held in
their head and limit the possible
confusion that may ensue when you are
talking about a particular variable
name and finally correct so remember
even if we had meaningful descriptive
names even if they were concise if
they're not correct they're useless to
us so correct the identifier needs to
convey what is actually being assigned
so with these three C's these are a bit
more explicit these are closer to the
syntactical rules that we've been given
and some hold as the you know law for us
to use but when it comes to the
semantics of how we name our variables
these three should very much guide you
in the right direction every time that
you are going and so specifically with
the correct we now want to go to
variable variables because this has all
been in theory so far so let's actually
see how we would go through and name
these things and we'll start with what I
consider the lwh hanging fruit the
easiest thing that we all should be
doing if we are not by now and that is
how we name booleans so booleans
should and can only beat one of two
values true or false they need to answer
a question yes or no and when you name
your Boolean they need to give you this
answer they need to read in this way
they need to convey that it is going to
give you a yes or a no and so with those
things we've come up with some
conventions where booleans are something
they could be an upgrade so is upgrade
or is approval or is PR member they
might do something so this does not mean
you take does and then add the word this
is what is the action that you are
trying to convey does it allow Whit
space it does will update did it restart
these all are also in the affirmative
because whenever you have to negate the
question and you read that in code it's
not fun to do a double negative that
just increases the cognitive load in
your head of okay what am I it is not
not restarting no wait it is not is not
active no so whenever you do try to name
booleans it's usually easier to read
when you do it in the
affirmative and finally something else
is it has something it has more than one
warning or it has multiple discounts or
has
exception so booleans should all be
following these types of guidelines
these should be much more clear and
easier to read and should also more
clearly convey what you are trying to
assess so if we were to name a Boolean
and the condition was we needed to
return true if at least one user is
active what would that name
be this is the code that it would be so
that something there is what we're
trying to
name so in one of the examples I found
someone said is users
active so so it would read cons is users
active it just sounds wrong right it's
grammatically incorrect it's not
actually true the condition we're trying
to find is if at least one user so this
kind of is confusing because you say is
users active so we're going to go not
with that one because it's already
grammatically incorrect we have is at
least one user
active it's a little bit better but it's
a little bit too wordy I think we can
get more concise with it so let's cross
that one out we do is one user
active should be waving red flags in
your head right now if you see this one
why would this one be red flaggy in your
head exactly so the condition that we
are trying to test for is return true if
at least one user is active but with
this particular variable name this is
very confusing it's a lie it says is one
specific user active or is it what else
we are trying to convey so this toes the
line between it's kind of concise and it
could be correct but it's not actually
what we're trying to convey so we're
going to cross that one out as
well another one is is some user active
so this one's a little bit better and in
JavaScript it follows the
array.prototype do suum convention but
we're going to cross this one out
because there's one more that is even
better that fits all three C and that's
is any user active is any user active
this would fulfill our condition this
does convey at least one and this is
much easier to read within the condition
so is any user active fulfills all those
three
seats next we'll go to integers and I
apologize if some of of this is uh very
much known to you but we have a lot of
different names here
yes has active users that works that
follows our convention this is one good
job thank you for that has active users
would also be
one so going back to integers things
that are understood oh I was saying I
apologize if you may know this already
but this is either going to be a really
excellent refresher or you can send this
to someone who has terrible
naming and say watch
this so things that are understood to be
numbers there counts or a number of
something so there are ways to just name
the integer itself because we
intrinsically know that it is a number
so things like age or year or maybe we
have a constant that says these are the
maximum amount of login attempts or we
have tool tip delay in milliseconds
you'll notice that we get more granular
more
explicit more
um uh detailed in the examples that I
share because the initial ones are like
yeah we know age is typically an integer
but we want to get to the very end we
want to be that explicit we want to say
what it is that we're trying to
convey or we could say number of
something so number of retries number of
descendence number of accounts or number
of days without rain
when you have to have a number of
something maybe you are using this in a
total or maybe you are needing to have
account of this this is a good pattern
to use sometimes you have something that
is a little bit fleeting like those uh
temporary variables where you are in the
middle of counting so maybe you have a
failure count this is an alternative you
have failure count or retry count or
maybe current cake inventory count which
mine is always going
up
and so now we come to another one so if
we want to return the number of eligible
discount items that are part of a
customer's order this is something that
was
used so this is very very explicit and
uh who here has heard of the German
naming
convention yes my man so this would be a
very great example of the German naming
convention there is a programmer in a
blog post I believe his name is
Chris I think last last name starts with
an S but they talked about this story
where he had a German colleague they're
both developers and whenever he would
review his code he would be frustrated
but he would also be happy because
whenever he would read his German
colleagues code it was so verbose but he
knew what he was talking about because
his variable names were usually this
long so while there is a an argument to
say it could be this long I think we
could make this a little bit more
concise so first we can contract that
within transaction to in transaction
right we can save a few characters there
then depending on the context we know
that we are in this transaction we can
actually remove in transaction and just
go to number of eligible items now most
people would call it a day and say hey
this is short this is descriptive it's
correct it's giving us what we want but
I'm going to argue and say we actually
want something like this number of
eligible discount items because it's
very clear that you're talking about
discount items what if in the future you
have another thing that is an eligible
item maybe it is a campaign that you say
only specific campaign items are
eligible or let's say something is not
part of the original store maybe it's a
popup store and you say these items are
not part of the main inventory that
could also convey the notion of an
eligible item which would not fit in the
future so another great thing about this
is that while it's a little bit more
work if you do think forward and you
think you may have to refactor it
because it doesn't convey the right uh
Concept in the future you can refactor
it to something like this where it is
more explicit but if you start out with
it in the first place then you know you
are very specifically talking about disc
items here and so this one would be the
winner for
here now we talk about floating Point
numbers so unrounded measures numbers
that are not
integers and these are pretty
self-explanatory in a sense so floating
Point numbers again are like integers
most of the ones that we know we kind of
know intrinsically that they are a
floating Point itself so height weight
price in Danish is it
or this well this be on the internet so
someone can phonetically spell it out in
the comments if I said it right or not
angle in degrees or getting to that very
specific very concise name high
temperature in fahrenheit when you read
a name like that you know exactly what
you are talking about there's no room
for misinterpretation there's no room
for error other than Maybe
you not understanding a particular word
there it's very unlikely that you're
going to not know this maybe here you'll
be like Fahrenheit what is that so maybe
you would refactor that to Centigrade
Celsius something amount similar to our
integers if the floating Point itself
does not convey as much as you need to
you can use this pattern as well so
maybe you have a discount amount or
maybe you have a transfer amount or a
refund amount these are things that
again are just a little bit more
explicit when you add the name amount
because you are dealing with it in this
nature strings so we are all familiar
with this they are typically a sequence
of characters and again they are fairly
good at being used as a variable name
itself so whatever the entity is that
you are discussing you can use that name
so full given name or city or short
speaker biography or player selected
class if you're in a video game or
definition most strings really really
convey what it is that we're trying to
talk about the more explicit that you
can be the better it is that the fellow
developers that you are writing code for
will understand what you are talking
about and there's different degrees to
which you have to be explicit right if
you are within a class and you are
already knowing that you are talking
about a person you don't have to
duplicate the name person in the
variable name you can just eliminate
that because you are within the context
however if you're outside of that and
you need to still convey the notion of a
person then maybe it would be good to
add person there but again person is a
very ambiguous name you want to be very
explicit you want to say who it is that
you're talking about is it a person or
is it a pro tier member is it a SST
admin is it there's all kinds of people
in the world so use your words and be
more explicit about who it is that
you're trying to talk about and what
you're trying to
convey and sometimes we need to parse
things as strings so this is a good way
to denote that when you have to use this
so you want to make sure that I know a
lot of us say we not supposed to tie the
implementation to it but there are
circumstances where we need to part
something as a string so indicating that
for example month as a string or time
zone as a string these are very common
things that sometimes we would need to
parse as a string but in the moment when
you're writing that and you are in the
context of that you're like yeah it's
the month I know what a month is and I
know that I'm just parsing it out to
fill this particular component to say
the month in a string format but when
you leave this context and you give this
to your fellow developer or you yourself
return three months from now you're
going to want to know why this is
returning as a string or maybe you still
know it but again why give yourself that
extra cognitive load of remembering what
it is that you were trying to do it
takes you a few more characters to just
say as a string and to do
it collections are another very common
thing that we need to deal with so these
are anything that is a group of things
arrays or lists or sets and so again
very similar to Strings except it's in a
plural format because we want to convey
that it is a group of a particular thing
so there's robots there's sentient
robots there is discounted
products
customers customers or newly released
books these are all examples of
depending on the context pretty good
names for variables that convey what it
is that we're talking
about sometimes we need to talk about
the imple implementation of it so we
talk about the implementation of things
so let's say you bring back an unordered
list of customers because in a
particular page you don't care about
alphabetizing them you just need here's
a list give me everything that we have
so you may want to convey that you want
to say this is an unordered list of
customers or you may want to pass that
on and say hey when you are dealing with
this particular uh piece of information
it's not ordered for you so here you go
or you want a Quee of first priority
tasks or you want an ordered set of
timestamps again in the moment it seems
like Overkill in the moment you have
that context in your head and you think
oh I have to write out a couple more
characters and really explain this but
you will thank yourself later for being
this explicit and your fellow developers
will thank you and people you've never
met who decide to take over the platform
and the applications that you're working
on will thank you because you were so
explicit so continue to error on the
side of being more explicit and more
descriptive than
not maps are another common thing when
we access values by keys and so very
good pattern to follow is key to Value
map so what it is that we are trying to
access by the key so if we had a book
and we wanted to find the author book
book ID to author map if we wanted to
find all of the order counts by customer
customer to order total map or if we
wanted to get a list of suppliers for
the products that we have product ID to
suppliers map it's very very intuitive
when you read it someone who has never
been in that codebase before can get a
better sense of what it is you're trying
to do here and again it just all comes
down to being more
explicit same thing in pairs and tupal
so this is one that I get a lot of um uh
push back on because it's kind of long
but I'm going to argue and say it has
helped me time and time again and it
it's just more explicit so Pairs and
tuples and it could be more but these
are things that are typically stored
together so pairs two things or tupes
three things sometimes more things so
for pairs we do first pair and second
pair so length and width sets and
repetitions for exercises current and
lifetime XP genus and
species now someone once said well why
do you have to have the end it's pretty
self-explanatory you're making it a
little too long can't you just do length
width or sets repetitions you could but
it's a little bit harder and when you
talk about the third example current and
lifetime XP if we did that current
lifetime
XP now it gets a little bit confusing
what are you trying to are you talking
about the current lifetime XP of this
particular user for this session or are
you trying to convey something else we
are trying to convey something else
because this is a pair we're trying to
convey the current XP the player has
right now and the lifetime XP so this is
why I say keep the end in there
especially when talking about Pairs and
tupal for tup or anything more first
second and third thing or and fourth
thing so as you have more things that
you are grouping together and you need
to name you would just remove the and
you wouldn't do first and second and
third and fourth you would not do that
you would only do it right before the
last item so for example you do height
width and depth in centimeters or
saturated trons and total fat in grams
or for color Pickers red green blue and
Alpha these are all really
legible these are all very clear what it
is you're trying to convey and you may
even have a notion of what function this
might belong to or what parameter this
might be uh just reading these names
because they are a bit more explicit
than the average
variable that is
true I'll end with this we've talked
about a lot of different things we've
talked about synonyms Hony homophones
homographs skull
skull too we have so many different
names so many different words that we
can use to describe our world and so
when we think about that and we start
choosing identifier names for our
programs the one thing I want you to
remember because there's so many other
quotes and maybe I'll get listed
somewhere on the internet great code is
understood rarely is it interpreted if
you keep that in mind and you choose
your identifier names that are correct
concise and consistent then I can assure
you the variable names you write will
not have you shaking your head in the
end thank you so
much so very quickly am I still on yeah
they didn't cut me off yet Sal means
thank you in talog Te so if just very
very very quickly if you do like this
please forget to rate my talk put the
little cards in if you enjoyed this that
is my Twitter if you're on there X
whatever you want to call it tweet about
it share about it let my boss know I'm
actually here and doing a
talk and uh one last thing um because I
didn't do any of it in the beginning but
um oh well that too if you please find
me if you know a good ptis or Bakery I
am all about sweets so if you know any
here please find me I want to find it
before I leave and I'm currently writing
a book called looks good to me good
constructive code reviews so if any of
how I've explained variable names was
interesting to you I would love for you
to check it out I talk about how to make
code reviews much better much more
Humane much more compassionate but I
also talk about how we can make them
more manageable if it takes too long
what do you do to not make it so long
why are we not using more automation to
get rid of silly comments like
indentation spacing those should not be
in there I talk about a whole bunch of
things about code reviews and I'd be
really happy if you just checked it out
and I am truly done now thank
[Applause]
you